hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weitere minecraft
roman fischer das ist ein command der
nur für die minecraft 1.9 funktioniert
deswegen hab ich 69 titel geschrieben
weil ich unter anderem auch eigentlich
noch 1.8 spielerei zu den command selber
ausprobieren wollte es ein link in der
beschreibung und ich zeige euch denn
jetzt das allererste was wir brauchen es
gift also für den player command
unterstrich opel
nachdem falschangaben habe ich jetzt
auch meine roman blog wo kinder 109
braucht allerdings für diesen command
blog einen lästigen schalter mehr
daneben setzen sondern die fügen hat bei
den command einklicken auf need redstone
dann wird das ganze hier nämlich schon
kreiert und wir haben das creation der
website findet die ganze infos in der
beschreibung es ist nicht so wie bei
anderen commands dass wir hier
draufklicken und an items bekommen
sondern wir müssen das bei ihnen ja
immer so ein bisschen selber uns
zusammen kraft ich habe mir jetzt hier
nämlich einfach mal so ein kleines büro
aufgebaut was ich allerdings habe ich
überhaupt schon gesagt was das für ein
command ist ihr habt wahrscheinlich
schon tippen lese aber das ist der
youtube com
da steht ja auch hier nochmal youtube
agiere ich habe ja schon mal ein youtube
command vorgestellt den verlinke ich
euch mal hier den könnt ihr euch am ende
des videos am besten anschauen oder
schon mal anklicken und dann am ende
dann hätten wir das auch geklärt hat
sich das video gemacht habe wurden so
sachen vorgestellt wie oh da könnt ihr
eine website youtube hier haben und
könnte dann darum scrollen und hab dann
internet in minecraft so in etwa was wir
hier jetzt allerdings haben ist wirklich
ein paar items die nur youtuber benutzen
also sowas wie beispielsweise eine
kamera daneben stehen haben oder eher
gut die anderen sachen benutzt
eigentlich jeder dabei gibt es dann
beispielsweise auch noch boxen
lautsprechern silberne playdom außen pc
in stuhl und das craften wir jetzt das
allerwichtigste ist natürlich der pc das
heißt wir schmeißen erstmal vier glas
auf den boden dann noch zwei redstone
tortoise und einen blog auf das ist gut
dass sich das direkt alles wieder
eingesammelt habt ihr seht schon ich
bekomme hier einen computer und kann
diesen computer jetzt einfach mal hier
hinsetzen ihr seht schon auf der
rückseite
ich bin runter fallen auf der rückseite
haben wir anstatt dem apple-logo einfach
so einen halben helm bzw
ein paar stunden später ja wenn ich das
jetzt mal gedreht habe wir können durch
den pc durchlaufen und man kann den pc
nur zerstören wenn man den block
darunter zerstört mache ich jetzt
allerdings nicht das kann ich euch am
ende mal demonstrieren als nächstes
brauchen wir natürlich eine maus um das
ganze zu bedienen dafür schmeißen wir
zwei stein buttons und zwei redstone und
wir haben schon eine maus und die können
wir jetzt einfach hier hinsetzen und ihr
seht schon wie sieht eigentlich echt
ganz schön heiß auf diese ganzen items
sind übrigens nur decorative das heißt
man kann mit denen jetzt nicht irgendwie
krass interagieren und irgendwie mit der
maus wirklich den pc dann steuern oder
irgend so ein quatsch machen dass es
damit leider nicht möglich allerdings
schmeißen jetzt erstmal vier winning
goals ticks unter dem letzten tor
stellen und bekommt schon eine kamera
die wir beispielsweise hier hinstellen
wieso ist denn da einen kopf drauf ich
weiß nicht wieso davor den kopf drauf
war aber jetzt habe das kamera sind wohl
wahrscheinlich ist das einfach in
minecraft court kopf aber
jetzt auf jeden fall die kamera und wir
haben jetzt im außen pc und eine kamera
bis nächstes benötigen wir natürlich ein
stuhl damit wir uns da auch vor setzen
können und nicht im stehen aufnehmen
müssen und zwar an den wir dafür einfach
einen traktor dann drei black cats und
ein android was genau ist eigentlich ein
android wird es ein komisches 1.9 alten
verschmerzen dass auch dahin und ihr
seht wir bekommen einen share können den
hier hinsetzen und ihr seht schon dann
können wir uns auch hier hinsetzen wenn
wir da nämlich einfach mal das ist das
einzige team mit dem wir interagieren
können als nächstes benötigen wir
lautsprecher und dafür benötigen wir s
dx ab und not blogs die wir uns jetzt
einfach mal erholen ich weiß nicht mehr
bei mir steht hier ich habe mir
natürlich wieder notizen immer steht für
einen lautsprecher benötige ich zwei
steaks und einen nord blog ich glaube
aber dann bekomme ich noch einen speaker
wenn ich das richtig sehe es liegt
ich bin ja im creative mutig spaß ich
denke man bekommt dann nur einen speaker
und erst einmal quasi weg weil das ganze
zeit zweifel guide friendly das heißt
ihr könnt das ganze auch wirklich machen
wenn ihr jetzt nicht im creative seid da
braucht man halt die alte es für das
heißt wenn ihr euch den computer basteln
wollt geht erst mal sand holen verbrennt
den und ab die glas und holt redstone
macht von tortoise und letzten block und
dann habt ihr alten computer und könnt
das ganze halt im survival singleplayer
whatever einfach ganz leicht selber
kreieren nur dann braucht man halt nicht
zwei sticks und einen nord blog für ein
lautsprecher sondern halt
dementsprechend für zwei lautsprecher 4
6 und 2 nord blogs allerdings auch wenn
ich hier die musik auf 42 prozent
gedreht habe oder auf 100 prozent hört
man hier nichts von den lautsprechern
die machen dann wahrscheinlich nur diese
komischen aufpoppenden teile hier immer
das nächste und letzte altem ist der
silberne play button dafür benötigen
einem blog auf ihren und ein item frame
dann bekomme den silva play button wohin
ich den jetzt hinter jeder server play
day hier kann man sich den selber
kräften in mir live bekommt man ihr herz
100.000 abonnenten den goldenen gibt es
ja bei 1.000.000 den kann man sich hier
allerdings nicht kräften sondern man
kann sich wirklich nur die alte machen
wir jetzt gerade schon dreht ja das ist
halt wenn ich mir jetzt denkt ja das
ganze packt mich vorab kann ich einfach
den block darunter abbauen geht der
speaker weg hier gehen die ganzen sachen
ihr weg wenn ich die abwehr nicht den
stuhl abbauen will den job darunter
einfach zerstören und ihr haltet ihr den
block darunter und schon hab ich jetzt
wieder im inventar riechen würde gerne
auch mal wissen was passiert wenn ich
die ganzen sachen jetzt beispielsweise
hierhin setzte einfach mal und jetzt die
maschine zerstören weil es bleibt da
okay das ist als das heißt sie können
quasi die maschine einfach machen in
eurer singleplayer welt euch die ganze
sache brauchten danach die maschine
zerstören und ihr habt immer noch das
war es allerdings auch schon mit dieser
minecraft command vorstellung für heute
ich fand man etwas weiter für die neue
version 9.04 mittlerweile ist youtube
minecraft ja total im flash wir machen
jedes video mit 1.9 weil zahlt dieses
erste wege updates seit einem jahr war
oder so
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
stelle euch dann kommt ein paar mal drin
vor weil der ganz heißes und waldschule
furniture decorative shit hinzufügt wenn
euch das video gefallen hat würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen wenn ihr
weitere command kennt die neiße in die
so ähnlich sind nur dekoratives
hinzufügen oder sowas wie beispielsweise
was ich euch hier vorgestellt habe so
ein riesiger boss und kämpfer und alles
dazu kamen dann schreibt mir das gerne
unten in die kommentare und dann würde
ich sagen sehen uns in einem nächsten
video wieder